when you first enter the world of
automated testing you might be
overwhelmed with some of the terminology
unit tests instrumented tests mocking it
can be a little daunting to even start
to learn about testing if you're
watching this video you're probably
looking for an answer to one simple
question how do I start adding tests to
my app don't worry that's what Android
testing patterns is all about but please
bear with me let's start with some
basics this is the testing pyramid it
represents the various levels or types
of tests you can add to your app unit
tests are perhaps the most basic type of
tests but basic is not the same as
unimportant in fact they should form the
foundation of your whole test strategy
that's why they sit at the bottom of the
pyramid
unit tests verify the correctness of the
smallest units of your code such as
methods and classes in isolation from
the rest of the code base or even the
platform they will be running on in fact
you can actually run unit tests for
Android apps on your computer thanks to
support from Android studio and Gradle
if it's unclear to you why you should
test code in isolation from Android
think of it this way how can you even
begin to check if your banking app for
example runs on an Android device
without first making sure that basic
business logic such as currency
conversions or calculating an account
balance work correctly but you are
writing an Android app after all so you
need to be able to test how your code
behaves on a real device or emulator and
that's when you want to use
instrumentation tests why do we call
them instrumentation or instrumented
test instrumentation is an android
framework component that provides
additional monitoring and control over
the application under test through the
use of instrumentation we can run tests
on a real device or emulator alongside
your app's code how does that work well
the test that you write will be packaged
into a separate apk and install as part
of the connected android test Gradle
task or run running tests in Android
studio
they will then be executed in your apps
process by an instrumentation runner we
provide a runner implementation that is
compatible with J unit 4
as part of the Android testing support
library or ATS L to use it make sure you
have the newest version of Android
support repository installed within your
SDK the adsl comes with a great UI
testing framework called espresso that I
will focus on in the next few episodes
of Android testing patterns it also
contains a unit for rules that can
automatically start activities and
services for your tests now I'm sure
you're all eager to see some testing in
action so be sure to click through to
the next video where I show you how to
run your first espresso test
you